(laughter)
- It was--
There's no fucking light
at the end of this tunnel.
It's just get colder.
I kept saying the word traumatic,
and I think it goes hand
in hand with what happens.
- [Narrator] We Googled potential benefits
and these are some of
the random completely
unproven side effects the
internet told us could happen
if we took cold showers.
- I just want to take cold showers
and suddenly fix my life.
If that can happen, we got an agreement.
- So I haven't done the research,
but I'm assuming it's
going to do things to me.
- So the first couple
of days, were terrible.
Oh man, my heart just started beating.
Yeah, let's see.
It's so cold.
I hate this.
So much.
I hate this
By about day five, I
think my body just started
getting accustom to the cold water.
Shower number five was
significantly easier.
I mean the initial blast
is going to be terrible,
but it's like jumping into a cold pool
just got to jump right in
and your body will adjust
to the temperature.
I would actually say,
I'm starting kinda to enjoy it.
I started learning the
less I thought about
taking a cold shower, the
easier it was to take it.
Shower number six felt great.
Cold shower number eight felt great.
I never thought I would
be a cold shower person
but I really love this.
- I really never got used to it.
It sucks. It sucks.
I'm telling you, you can never,
never get used to this.
It's not possible.
Anyone who says they got used to it,
100% they are lying.
- I was really shocked,
about half way through this,
I was voluntarily taking cold showers.
I found myself excited
to take cold showers
and looking forward to it.
I just got back from a
night out with my friends,
and I'm kinda drunk.
I really want a cold shower to
kinda sober me up a little bit.
But I never thought, i'd be like,
voluntarily taking a cold shower.
But I want to.
Cold showers are great for hangovers.
That shower was
incendiary.
So cold shower definitely
gave me a lot more energy.
On the days I was hungover
or the rainy days when I was lethargic.
- Energized part believe it.
It's like adrenaline going through
and incredible amounts.
Just like right now,
I'm feeling very, very energized.
Like, again, having many cups of coffee.
You feel energized as fuck.
and by that I mean,
beast mode.
Like Hulk.
whatever you call that creature
is going to come out of you
and you better watch out.
- Cold shower 19 felt great,
and I am ready to dominate the day.
By the time I was out, I was energized.
I was rejuvenated, ready
to take on the day.
- So you get excited
and went oh my god this cold shower,
I'll take this.
But half an hour later,
you go back to your usual self
and you're like dragging
like what is going on.
You're just back to being lazy.
I'm here.
I'm fine.
My skin is looking amazing.
It really is.
One of the things I noticed,
was definitely the skin.
My skin all over feels great.
Face, arms, everything looks amazing.
- My skin has been incredible.
And my hair has never felt smoother.
Typically, I have terrible
bags under my eyes
that don't go away, and
those have been better
My energy.
My mood.
Everything has been a lot better.
- I think there was an evolution in there.
So after complaining
about my hair looking dry
and unhealthy,
hair looks super dry, oh my god,
I thought it was going to do
marvelous things to my hair.
That is finally changing,
my hair is looking
better, healthier, shinier
it's looking pretty good.
Even my husband was like,
oh my god, it's looks shiny.
It looks like you healthy, normal, hair,
for the very first time.
And I was like, oh my god,
that is freaking true.
It looks like I actually stylized it
but truth is, I barely brushed it.
The volume is beautiful.
The shine.
It looks so strong
- I would say,
one of the biggest benefits
of taking a cold shower
was that I was significantly
less sweaty than I normally am.
Oh my god, ya'll, typically this by point,
I would have slowly started to sweat
through my entire shirt.
Even in an air conditioned subway,
but no sweat, no sweat marks on the shirt,
I think I can vibe with the cold shower.
I think I get it now.
Day 30.
The last day of the cold shower challenge.
I never thought I would
have made it this far
with this much acceptance.
I've seen so many health
benefits from this.
I'm not sweating. My skin's better.
My hair's better.
My mood is better.
I'm ready. I'm a little sad
to take my last cold shower.
- Never get used to it.
It will be pretty cool to know,
that taking a hot shower is okay.
I can't wait for this to be over.
- If you can commit to taking
a cold shower in the morning,
which is something that's not enjoyable
and then you can almost
reach this meditative place
where you're trying not
thinking about the cold water
and you're just trying to enjoy it.
And you're trying to push
those negative feelings
and negative thoughts out,
then that really kinda just
overlaps into your day.
- Sort of like, this cathartic experience,
but do I feel philosophical today?
No, fuck it.
- That's something I really
love about the cold showers,
just the will power and
the comittment it took.
- Did I enjoy it?
Like genuinely enjoyed it?
No, absolutely not.
- I think this is something
I'm going to adopt.
- ♫ She's a maniac, manic, oh no no.
♫ Here it comes.
♫ Oh my god. This was--
♫ Fuck.
♫ Oh shit.